hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to with another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make
learning math a lot less stressful so in
this video what we're going to do is
we're going to talk about some more
difference quotient examples okay so to
give you some more practice and just
give you some more understanding about
how to do the difference quotient so if
you want you can pause the video and go
ahead and try to do the difference
quotient here on your own and then we'll
go through these together so just
another way to get some extra practice
so what I'm going to do here is I'm
going to find the difference quotient of
f of X equals 1 over X minus 5 so just a
quick refresher this is the difference
quotient here and students get a little
bit confused sometimes about you know
what goes in for what right you know
what substitution are we making and let
me see if I can just show you how this
works so whatever is in the parentheses
okay that's the input that's what you're
putting into your function in place of X
so we're going to do is going to go to
our function okay right here and
whatever is in the parentheses that's
our input that's what goes in for X okay
on the right side so we're going to be
replacing X with X plus h so this is
going to be 1 over X plus h minus 5
minus okay that's this minus here f of X
and I just think of that as f of X is
just this whole function the original
function so 1 over X minus 5 divided by
H and it's the limit as H is approaching
0 okay now you don't want to make this
mistake you don't want to put 0 in too
soon if you do you're going to get 0
over 0 which is an indeterminate form
which means that you know we can't
really you know really make any
conclusions about this at this point so
we really want is we want to simplify
this down further okay before we
substitute 0 in for H so what we're
going to do here is we're going to
multiply by the common denominator so
what we're doing is we're gonna multiply
by X plus h minus 5 and X minus 5 but
whatever you do to the numerator we want
to do to the denominator right because
we want to keep this equivalent so we
just want them this is like multiplying
by the number 1 so what I'm going to do
here is I'm going to distribute this
quantity to this fraction and to this
fraction okay so you're with me so far
so when we do that we
distribute that to this fraction the X
plus h minus five and this X plus h
minus five they're going to cancel one
another out you're just going to have X
minus five times one which is X minus
five minus right when we distribute this
to this fraction the X minus 5s are
going to cancel out because this is in
the numerator this is in the denominator
right so we're just going to have 1
times X plus h minus 5 now you want to
be careful because when you're
subtracting you're really subtracting
this entire thing so some students
forget to put the parentheses you want
to treat this as a group okay and you're
subtracting this entire group okay and
then the last step here is we're just
going to multiply this whole thing times
the denominator but don't foil the
denominator just leave it in factored
form and you'll see why in a minute
because we're going to get some
cancellation that occurs okay so now
what we can do is we can distribute this
negative okay so that's going to be X
minus 5 minus X minus H plus 5 so we're
just distributing like so and that's all
over H times X plus h minus 5 times X
minus 5 and you can see the X's are
cancelling the 5s are cancelling we're
just left with negative H over H and now
what you can do is you can divide these
both by H you're just going to be left
with negative 1 over X plus h minus 5
times X minus 5 it's the limit as H
approaches 0 we can put 0 now in for H
and we're just left with negative 1 over
X minus 5 times X minus 5 which is X
minus 5 squared so this is our
difference quotient and again remember
what the difference quotient is this is
a formula it's a general formula for
finding the slope ok the rate of change
at any point along this graph so if we
wanted to find well what's the slope of
the tangent line when X is 4 right it's
going to be 4 minus 5 which is negative
1 negative 1 squared is 1 negative 1
divided by 1 is negative 1 so it's going
to have a negative 1 slope but if we
were to do it at let's say when X is 10
you know you're going to get a different
slope because right you know the graph
is not going
at a continuous rate so let's look at
another example let's look at this one
over here f of X equals x cubed plus two
okay so we're going to go through that
same exact process so what we're going
to do is we're going to substitute X
plus h in for X okay now if there was
another X here right here we would also
put X plus h in for that X as well so
wherever whatever is inside this
parentheses is going to go in for X on
the right side of the equation okay
that's how functions work this is the
input and the f of X is the y-value
that's the output but in this case we
just have one X here so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to place X with X
plus h the quantity cubed plus 2 okay so
that's that's this part here minus f of
X which is the original function that's
this whole thing right here so minus X
cubed plus 2 all divided by H that's the
limit as H is approaching 0 so now we're
going to do is we're going to expand
this out X plus h cubed ok if you
remember Pascal's triangle I'll go over
here remember Pascal's triangle 1 1 1 2
1 1 3 3 1 ok these are the coefficients
we're going to use this to expand so
this is actually going to be X cubed
plus 3x squared h plus 3x h squared plus
h cubed plus 2 minus X cubed minus 2 I'm
just distributing the negative all
divided by H now if you want to see this
you can do this another way too you
could write this as X plus h 3 times ok
oil these two together get an answer
then distribute the X and then
distribute the H simplify and you're
going to get this but using Pascal's
triangles gonna be a lot faster okay so
now we're just going to simplify the X
cubes cancel because ones positive one
is negative the 2s and the negative 2's
are going to cancel and you notice how
each term each group has an H in it so
what we're going to do is we have after
that each out okay so we're going to
factor the H out this is going to be 3x
squared plus 3x H plus h squared all
divided by H
and you can see the HS are canceling a
numerator and denominator all right so
now remember it's the limit as H is
approaching zero if I put zero in for H
this whole term is going to be zero and
this is going to be zero and we're left
with three x squared so this is our
difference quotient simplified and
remember what the difference quotient is
it's actually a general formula okay for
finding the slope anywhere along this
graph so if I wanted to find the slope
of the tangent line at x equals one
right the slope would be 1 squared is 1
times 3 is 3 so we would have a you know
an incline at that point of 3 and
instantaneous rate of change so I hope
this helped you I hope you are
understanding how to work with the
difference quotient better I'll have
some links and the cards for some of my
other videos regarding the same topic
and I look forward to seeing you in some
of the future videos I'll talk to you
soon